artificial intelligence and machine
learning what's the difference are they
the same well some people kind of frame
the question this way it's AI versus ml
is that the right way to think of this
or is it AI
equals
ml
or is it AI is somehow something
different than ml
so here's three equations
I wonder which one is going to be right
well let's talk about this first of all
when we talk about AI I think it's
important to come with definitions
because a lot of people have different
ideas of what this is so I'm going to
assert the simple definition that AI is
basically exceeding or matching
the capabilities of a human so we're
trying to match the intelligence
whatever that means and capabilities of
a human subject
now what could that involve there's a
number of different things for instance
one of them is the ability to discover
to find out new information another is
the ability to infer to read in
information from other sources that
maybe has not been explicitly stated and
then also the ability to reason
the ability to figure things out I put
this and this together and I come up
with something else so I'm going to
suggest to you this is what AI is and
that's the definition we'll use for this
discussion now what kinds of things then
would be involved if we were talking
about doing machine learning well
Machine learning I'm going to put that
over here is basically a capability
we'll start with a Venn diagram machine
learning involves predictions or
decisions based on data think about this
as a very sophisticated form of
statistical analysis it's looking for
predictions based upon information that
we have so the more we feed into the
system the more it's able to give us
accurate predictions and decisions based
upon that data it's something that
learns that's the L part rather than
having to be programmed when we program
a system I have to come up with all the
code and if I wanted to do something
different I have to go change the code
and then get a different outcome in the
machine learning situation what I'm
doing could be adjusting some models but
is different than programming and mostly
it's learning the more data that I give
to it so it's based on large amounts of
information and there's a couple of
different fields within couple of
different types there is supervised
machine learning and as you might guess
there's an unsupervised machine learning
and the main difference as the name
implies is one has more human oversight
looking at the training of the data
using labels that are superimposed on
the data unsupervised is kind of able to
run more uh and and find things that
were not explicitly stated
okay so that's machine learning it turns
out that there's a subfield of machine
learning that we call Deep learning
and what is deep learning well this
involves things like neural networks
neural networks involve nodes and
statistical relationships between those
nodes to model the way that our minds
work
and it's called Deep because we're doing
multiple layers of those neural networks
now the interesting thing about deep
learning is we can end up with some very
interesting insights but we might not
always be able to tell how the system
came up with that it doesn't always show
its work fully so we could end up with
some really interesting information not
know in some cases how reliable that is
because we don't know exactly how it was
derived but it's still a very important
part of all of this realm that we're
dealing with so those are two areas and
you can see DL is a subset of ml but
what about artificial intelligence where
does that fit in the Venn diagram
and I'm going to suggest to you it is
the superset of mldl and a bunch of
other things what could the other of
things be well we can involve things
like natural language processing uh it
could be vision
so we want a system that's able to see
we might even want a system that's able
to hear and be able to distinguish what
it's hearing and what it's seeing
because after all humans are able to do
that and that's part of what our brains
do is distinguish those kinds of things
it can involve other things like the
ability to do text to speech
so if we take written words Concepts and
be able to speak those out so this first
one involved being able to see things
this is now being able to speak those
things as well
and then other things that humans are
able to do naturally that we often take
for granted is motion this is the field
of Robotics which is a subset of AI the
ability to just do simple things like
tie our shoes open and close the door
lift something walk somewhere that's all
something that would be part of human
capabilities and involves certain sorts
of perceptions calculations that we do
in our brains that we don't even think
about so here's what it comes down to
it's a Venn diagram and we've got
machine learning We've Got Deep learning
and we've got AI so I'm going to suggest
to you the right way to think about this
is not these equations those are not the
way to look at it in fact what we should
think about this as machine learning is
a subset of a high
and that's how we need to think about
this when I'm doing machine learning in
fact I am doing AI when I'm doing these
other things I'm doing AI but none of
them are all of AI but they're a very
important part
thanks for watching please remember to
like this video And subscribe to this
channel so we can continue to bring you
content that matters to you